when I was in high school so we're
talking from 1984 to
1988. I remember my mother working at
several different places at several
different kinds of jobs in Waukesha
Wisconsin which is a city we eventually
moved to my senior year we were living
out in Wales or rather the township of
Delafield just north of Wales for quite
a long time and my my dad died when I
was in Middle School actually in the
year between sixth and seventh grade
there's a whole long story about that
and I'll I'll link to that below but
long story short we went from being sort
of you know a solidly middle class
because my my dad was a tax attorney it
going back into working class once again
with my dad's dad my grandpa Joe the
hardcore or alcoholic living with us and
my mom having to go back to work I was
still able to go to university Lake
school private school because I had a
scholarship and frankly they probably
also felt sorry for our family
um and then you know I eventually would
go to Catholic Memorial High School in
in Waukesha
and so
um you know life was in some respects
not terrible but also not great in a lot
of ways and anyway back to my mom
working
um I remember her being hired to work at
um one of our neighbors places
um and then she also worked at this uh
um
office supply store for a while but one
of the jobs that she had that I wanted
to tell you about here
was as a receptionist which she was very
good at doing
um at the school of Aesthetics and
Cosmetology on Racine Avenue in Waukesha
Wisconsin now it sounds very fancy but
Aesthetics primarily means makeup just
like the cosmetology and then they also
did you know manicures and pedicures
and you know hair cutting and various
like scalp treatments and I'm sure they
also did like you know facial stuff as
well although I don't I don't quite
remember this is a long time ago and so
it was quite interesting because the
person who owned this
um was uh the mother of one of my
classmates actually she wasn't in my
class she was in a few classes that
overlay but she was one grade lower than
me and her name was Tammy Olden how
often she had I think a younger
sister who was my sister's age and I
actually had a crush on Tammy for a
while and I think she did on me as well
but we were both kind of shy and awkward
kids so we actually did have one outing
where
um she came to her mom dropped her off
at our place
my mom made spaghetti then drove us to
Skate World in Waukesha left us alone
for a while we skated together
um chatted quite a bit and then
um
my mom picked us up and we we went home
that was the only time we did that so
anyway her mom I don't remember what her
mom's name was she was just Mrs
oldenhoff you know
and she was you know somebody who kind
of fit the bill for owning a school of
Aesthetics and cosmetology it was the
80s so she had some really significant
hair you know hair
gel and mousse and hairspray was like
very big and and you know haircuts would
be quite Buffon let's just say
so anyway
um I would be there quite a bit and
there were really two main reasons why I
would be there so one was that I would
quite often walk there from uh from
school so you know Catholic Memorial
would get out and we sometimes had
carpools and that was cool so you'd
catch a ride with kids who lived in the
same area as you but you didn't really
have all that much in common with
necessarily
um and sometimes even the kids would
drive you know when they got older but a
lot of times I would go to where my mom
was working and then catch a ride from
her that way
so you know there was a good bit of
um heading from the the school walking
down racing Avenue which for me was kind
of fun you know it was like getting to
the big city walk so it's not really a
big city but when you're from the sticks
like Wales and Delafield back in the 80s
it it sure feels bigger right and you
know it was pretty common to walk miles
and miles we did that a lot as as kids
and so I'd walk down there and um you
know hang around until my mom got off of
work and uh it's funny too when I think
about it so the students there were
studying essentially to become makeup
artists
beauticians you know hair cutters people
who would give manicures and pedicures
and all that kind of stuff
and it was considered to be like one of
the better places to go and there was
like a whole curriculum that they would
have to
study and these you know these these
women I was actually going to call them
girls
in part because you know they they were
all like
After High School right so they're all
18 19 20. there might be a few older
ones in there where they're doing like a
career change but they they were not
going to college this was their career
choice for for life and you know more
power to them we need people who like to
do that kind of stuff and get good at it
and take pride in that work and
um you know sometimes they would come
out and chat with me and I I consider
this really cool because you know I was
14 15 16.
I think it may have gone on to the time
that I was 17 but maybe she was done
working by then and you know I was kind
of shy and awkward myself but I was six
foot three by the time I entered high
school and I looked older than my age
and I'd also gotten into heavy metal and
so I was trying to grow my hair long I
never really succeeded in it in part
because of one of the stories I'll I'll
tell you but um you know I would be
there quite frequently and so sometimes
I'd just be hanging around reading a
book sometimes listening to my
headphones
um sometimes I would actually be there
because I would have biked into Waukesha
along the Drumlin Trail
um you know I started working in
Waukesha when I was 15 years old and I
had buddies you know who lived in
various parts of Waukesha that I would I
would connect up with and hang out with
and do things with too so you know
towards the end of the day I'd bike down
Racine Avenue and meet up with my mom
there but I also got a lot of things
done there for free because each of
these young women needed to get a
certain number of either hours or
procedures along certain lines done
and so I got a lot of haircuts and as a
matter of fact so
this is something that was like a
constant battle between me and my mom
she didn't want me to have long hair
because she thought it looked bad and
you know it would be
too much right I was already like
looking like a burnout anyway like
wearing a jean jacket eventually a
leather jacket and listening to you know
this this terrible music and and all
that sort of stuff hanging out with with
terrible people too and so she she would
bribe them she'd slip them a couple
bucks
to cut my hair more than I wanted it I
was always saying just cut off the very
ends take maybe an inch off you know I
just want to grow it out and the haircut
would finish and they'd have cut like
three or four inches off right and this
is the era of the mullet too so the most
I could actually get was a mullet I
couldn't just grow my hair out like I
have it now where it's all basically I
think the same length more or less it
hangs down past my shoulders if I take
it out no there it was always short in
the front and then it could be longer in
other ways and so you know my hair grew
pretty fast
so it needed trims quite a bit the the
women who worked there they really liked
my hair uh I I guess it was good hair
you know for the era nice and straight
with a little bit of waviness in it you
know brown with a little bit of red in
it and I guess a good texture or
something like that so they they were
constantly after me just about every
time I got a haircut it could have been
too because they needed to get a certain
number of these done they always wanted
to give me a perm and I I was always
like no I don't want a perm you know I
don't need it curly or poofed up I've
got like you know mousse if I want to
spike it or put it up like that
um
but it was getting towards the era for
metal heads where there was like a big
Divergence between the hair metal the
pop or light or glam metal which did
involve like big big hair right and
hairspray and stuff like that and then
what we called the real metal you know
what we nowadays recognize is
traditional heavy metal and thrash metal
were also becoming big and the aesthetic
with that was you don't put your hair up
big you actually let it hang and so I
you know getting a permanent would mean
like going over not to the dark side but
to the light side and so I wasn't keen
on that but I didn't let them uh you
know give me manicures and it was funny
because they were like oh you've got
such wonderful cuticles and I was like
thanks I guess you know I mean I'm not
doing anything with them and every once
in a while they'd ask me like what's
your routine for this and I'd be like
routine and what are you talking about
you know the idea that somebody would
like especially a guy would spend time
on aspects of their appearance unless it
was a medical thing was a little bit
weird to me right but this is a whole
different world right this is a world
where people are are thinking constantly
about using products and procedures on
your body to you know engage in
Aesthetics to make it look better or or
beautiful or handsome or whatever
and so you know I remember all sorts of
interesting things like getting scalp
massages getting my hair shampooed you
know you'd have to lean back in that
sink I had some dandruff so they used
this electric rake on me where like it
would zap your scalp and I guess it was
supposed to like promote you know
a better scalp growth or something like
that lots of manicures uh as I mentioned
lots of haircuts I think sometimes they
would do like neck massages as well but
it was pretty light and you know didn't
didn't do an awful lot for me but I
might be misremembering that but I do
remember it was kind of funny looking
back on it
these women flirted with me a lot there
was a lot of like jostling up against
you and you know almost like putting
their bodies uh on you and asking about
it I have a girlfriend was I seeing
anybody you know and for a long time uh
you know freshman year sophomore year I
was bashful you know I I had older girls
you know sending me notes and trying to
invite
I mean to various events and my mom was
actually also very protective of me when
it came to that sort of stuff a little
overprotective
um I only got to go to parties because
her boyfriend was like you actually got
to stop Sheltering this this kid Monique
that was my mom's name
and so I got to go to parties where
there were there were girls and older
girls you know in the area but um you
know I I kind of recognized it and kind
of didn't recognize it at the time
um and uh you know I never followed up
on anything with these older women at
the school of Aesthetics and cosmetology
who you know are like college age
students now you know and I think I was
as quite young because I'm I'm much
older but at the time you know I was uh
you know quite quite young myself so you
know that that's the sort of stuff that
went on there and you get to know some
of them they didn't none of them stayed
there all that long because it wasn't
like a place where you would go for
years and years I think maybe you did
like six months or so and then you would
you know get your diploma or whatever it
was and then go start working for a
salon or you know one those discount
hair cutting places or go off on your
own or I don't know what what they did
after that but it was kind of like a not
a rotating door but give it enough time
and uh the people would be shifting out
um but my mom worked there she really
liked it I think she liked chatting with
not just the owner uh but also with
um these these women who are going
through the course there my mom was very
gregarious very outgoing
and so yeah it was quite a quite a
interesting experience
I remember you know very distinctly
being on my 10-speed bicycle and like
zooming down Racine Avenue with my
headphones in my cassette playing you
know like sometimes it was Van Halen
sometimes it was rat sometimes it was
Mega Death you know sometimes it was
Iron Maiden all sorts of metal stuff
that I was listening to and like just
making you know progress down down that
road to
hang out there and catch a ride home
with my mom you know we'd throw the the
bike in the back
um for a while she had the station wagon
that my dad had bought so that was quite
easy to do so uh School of Aesthetics
and Cosmetology on Racine Avenue in
Waukesha I don't think it's there
anymore I think I may have looked for it
years back but something that I
definitely remember as being you know a
pretty important fixture of my high
school life